dans cette rentrée la croissance fléchit
et tout le monde feint de penser que ce
serait une nouvelle tombée du ciel mais
c'était manuel macron qui responsable de
la voir asphyxiés en ayant autant
augmenter les impôts sur les français et
c'est lui qui s'apprête à alourdir
encore les contraintes sur les
entreprises alors qu'il y a déjà
tellement de poids est tellement de
contrôles dans notre pays les motifs
d'inquiétude pour les entrepreneurs et
les pme sont malheureusement de plus en
plus nombreux pour tous ces hommes et
ces femmes qui savent ce que le travail
le sacrifice veulent dire la vie devient
de plus en plus difficile du fait des
charges des normes et les taxes imposées
par emmanuel macron nous sommes devenus
le premier pays d'europe en termes de
prélèvements obligatoires
avec un taux de 45% les produits
intérieurs bruts ce triste record
emmanuel macron à multiplier les
contraintes le prélèvement à la source
par exemple qui s'appliquera dès le 1er
janvier et qui va être une usine à gaz
avec des coûts techniques et de gestion
qui vont aller jusqu'à 1,2 milliard
d'euros qui vont peser sur ces
entreprises aux républicains nous disons
que ce n'est pas aux entreprises de
prélever l'impôt de leurs salariés et à
l'initiative d'eric woerth
nous proposons une alternative simple
c'est un paiement mensualisé est quasi
contemporain des revenus et comme si
cela ne suffisait pas la baisse des
charges prévues pour les entreprises a
été reportée de soi charge
supplémentaire sur les entreprises de 2
milliards d'euros en 2019 et puis il ya
le projet de taxation des contrats à
durée déterminée la baisse prive de 5
milliards d'euros sur les aides aux
entreprises ou le fait comme agnès musan
est en train de le dire que il y à une
possible prise en charge des arrêts
maladie par les entreprises tout cela
est insupportable
ceux qui travaillent prennent des
risques font des sacrifices se lève tôt
doivent être aidés et doivent voir leur
vie facilité
malheureusement avec emmanuel macron
c'est tout l'inversé
demain nous devons changer tout cela